These toads are impostors,
They’re the latest example of using 3D-printing
to study animal behavior.
With the first rains, neotropical yellow toads
begin an intense breeding season
that can last little more than a day.
For this brief period, the male toads switch
their normal drab brown to a vibrant lemon-yellow.
This year they will be joined by a handful of
impersonators, as scientists try to find out more
about the toads’ mating behavior
The researchers will place a female into an arena
with two 3D-printed male Robo-toads,
one more brightly colored than the other.
By recording which model the female prefers,
they hope to find out how the intensity of yellow
affects the female’s choice-- something previously
difficult to accomplish with hand-made replicas.
Researchers have also used 3D-printing to look at
the mating preferences of the northern map turtle.
The males are known to breed with females
up to 10 times their mass.
But is size something these males are looking for?
Scientists printed two models of female turtles,
identical except for their size,
and placed them at the bottom of a lake.
The wild male turtles attempted to mate
with the larger of the two females more often,
suggesting that size is an important consideration
for these turtles.
Ornithologists have used 3D printed eggs--
to study how robins deal with eggs from
parasitic cowbirds that are laid in their nests.
With 3D printing, researchers can create cowbird eggs
that vary subtly in size and shape--
and their research can now be reproduced
by others using the same 3D model.
Once any of these models have been created,
it can easily be mass-produced.
Despite these advantages --
3D-printed animals are still rare in research.
But as 3D printers get more common and less complex
you might want to keep an eye out
for wildlife imposters.